[Music]
hi guys i'm lauren zima we are here at
UCLA celebrating Travis walls shaping
sound after the curtain he's a famous
choreographer and we talked to another
famous dancer
Maddie Ziegler about the show she left
behind Dance Moms and what's going on
with our next have you talked to Abby
Lee Miller at all no I haven't no were
you surprised by the news of what's
happening for her I don't really think I
have anything to say about her yeah and
I gotta ask you you and your boyfriend
are super cute on Instagram how's that
going it's great I see you in six days
so I'm very excited yeah good you just
got very good but last time I talked to
you were like I'm taking it slow and
keeping a ground did I know I'm a
teenager so you're very grounded in it
that's awesome
yeah I mean yeah I would never like move
things too quick and plus I know I'm
still 14
you know like I'm still like child so
but yeah jack was really great and
that's great I have a good time with him
so what's next for you girl I'm going
back on tour with SIA and we're doing an
Australian tour and we're going to New
Zealand so I'm so excited that's at the
end of the year so it should be great in
one word how would you describe the tour
with c.x people are gonna be excited
like insane it's literally insane
you
[Music]